buongiorno a tutti
avete sentito molti relatori che mi
hanno preceduto molto presentazione che
mi hanno preceduto che hanno parlato
degli aspetti relativi al cervello in
termini di evoluzione progressione dal
punto di vista di quello che è la
potenza dei sistemi di calcolo in
termini di capacità di simulare del
comportamento mediante il robot del in
termini di biomateriali
quali costruire circuiti che possono
essere messi direttamente in
comunicazioni neurologico con cervello
abbiamo cercato con questo progetto
human brain di mettere tutto questo
assieme e di realizzare una piattaforma
che possa far sì che la progressione
esponenziale di evoluzione di quelle che
sono le conoscenze che hanno a che fare
con lo studio del cervello possa
accelerare nel corso dei prossimi cinque
anni che cosa human brain è un progetto
che è stato completamente finanziato
dalla commissione europea sul quale
abbiamo lavorato negli ultimi quattro
anni semplicemente per idearlo è che si
svolgerà nei prossimi quattro anni da
questo punto di vista l'europa è molto
più avanti rispetto agli stati uniti
solo recentemente anche con un'azione
diretta da parte del presidente obama
gli stati uniti hanno deciso di
agire
cominciando ad ideare un progetto di
human brain e questo progetto a questo
punto è in corso la prima fase è già in
attività nel corso dei prossimi dieci
anni ci sarà la mobilizzazione di oltre
un miliardo di euro per realizzare
quello che lo studio del cervello umano
un consorzio di molte centinaia di
laboratori in europa di molte centinaia
di istituzioni in in europa e anche che
mette in relazione la nostra conoscenza
nel con gli stati uniti con il giappone
è con la cina la prima cosa che abbiamo
realizzato questo è già stata realizzata
è stata una piattaforma
informatica era assolutamente necessario
mettere a disposizione della comunità
dei ricercatori una piattaforma infatti
matica che consentisse loro di poter
fare un certo numero di cose che
cercherò di dire rapidissimamente come
realizzare questa piattaforma
informatica mettendo i laboratori di
simulazione e di sviluppo software in
collegamento con quelli che sono i
quattro maggiori sistemi di supercalcolo
presenti in europa di cui uno è presente
in italia al cineca e che rappresenta il
punto di riferimento per quello che
riguarda il data processing di tutti i
dati che vengono collezionati in europa
relativamente allo studio del cervello
umano c'è un'altra cosa molto importante
che si è realizzato mediante questa
piattaforma che è la collaborazione di
una comunità scientifica che mette
assieme anche dal punto di vista di
quello che è l'interazione dunque il
linguaggio allo scopo di uno stesso
obiettivo
discipline molto diverse fra loro
discipline che vanno dalla biologia alla
neurologia alla fisica la chimica
l'informatica alle discipline di tipo
ingegneristico
ovviamente di tipo medico ma anche a
competenze e intellettuali come per
esempio l'etica che in un qualche modo
proporrà quelli che sono i limiti
rispetto a tutta la sperimentazione che
verrà svolta e anche la filosofia qual è
come dire il limite ultimo rispetto al
quale ci si può spingere
nell'attività di realizzare una
piattaforma che ha lo scopo di simulare
il comportamento del cervello umano
il progetto si compone di tre aree che
sono
sinergiche e complementari una all'altra
un area relativa quelle che a quelle che
sono le neuroscienze la metrica che
viene utilizzata in quest'area è quella
dello spazio nel senso che noi
conosciamo
come funzionano
avete sentito anche nelle presentazioni
precedenti quelli che sono i vari
componenti che costituiscono la
struttura del cervello
e siamo anche singolarmente in grado di
diciamo simularli e anche per certi
versi di realizzarli in vitro i vari
componenti il punto è la complessità di
questi componenti assieme fanno sì che
il nostro cervello
è in grado di avere delle funzioni di
tipo cognitivo
e inoltre il nostro cervello è in grado
di avere delle
funzioni legate al comportamento
come la struttura della del cervello far
partire dai geni dalle proteine dalle
sinapsi da gli assoni
funziona assieme
facendoci comprendere ea avendo un
comportamento questa cosa ancora non
siamo in grado di capirla ma da questo
punto di vista riteniamo che ci siano le
condizioni per compiere dei passi avanti
importanti in questo senso la seconda
cosa è la medicina la metrica e la scala
che viene utilizzata in questo ambito è
quella del tempo cioè evidentemente una
evoluzione che può anche dare delle
comportare degli aspetti carattere
degenerativo e comunque in qualche modo
l'apprendimento la conoscenza
l'elaborazione a che fare con
l'evoluzione del tempo l'evoluzione nel
tempo della raccolta di quelle che sono
le informazioni che non qualche modo
sono tenute a partire da quelli che sono
i dati diagnostici ed a quelli che sono
i dati sperimentali ci consentono di
derivare quelle che sono le
singolarità del sistema cromosomico che
può essere in un qualche modo
agito mediante quelli che sono delle
le azioni dei principi attivi
farmaceutici conosciuti il punto è
definire un profilo
considerando quello che è l'insieme dei
dati disponibili che in un qualche modo
definisce quello che è il target che
possiamo in un qualche modo andare ad
intaccare mediante un principio attivo e
poi simulare il comportamento del
principio attivo che in un qualche modo
corregge una patologia ea quel punto
poter effettuare una terapia dunque
muovere un passo avanti importante nella
direzione della medicina personalizzata
della possibilità di curare di trattare
a partire da quella che è la conoscenza
della struttura del cervello ma può
pagandola poi su tutta quella che è la
struttura del corpo umano
la possibilità di andare a sviluppare
una medicina che sia di tipo
personalizzato nei confronti dei
pazienti da ultimo il sistema e qui la
scala e quella dell'energia
il sistema del cervello come sistema di
elaborazione delle informazioni
il cervello umano è il sistema di
elaborazione delle formazioni più
complesso che noi conosciamo peraltro il
sistema assolutamente più potente il
sistema che ha una assoluta complessità
dal punto di vista multitasking funziona
in modo multitasking assolutamente
meraviglioso
noi siamo in grado di ricostruire le
immagini che vediamo è ricostruire le
immagini è un'azione informatica molto
pesante che esperti di videogiochi sa
che ottenere un
rendering fotorealistico di quello che è
un personaggio di un videogioco è molto
onerosa dal punto di vista
computazionale ma nostro cervello e lo
fa mentre noi parliamo mentre abbiamo un
atteggiamento coordinato e mentre
pensiamo mentre noi diamo informazioni
questo sistema è un sistema che è il
sistema più complesso per l'elaborazione
delle informazioni anche il sistema più
potente la stima è che la potenza di
elaborazione del cervello umano sia
nell'ordine di
elsa flop di potenza un aiuto flop è
alcuni miliardi di miliardi di
operazioni al secondo
è il nostro cervello le esegue
consumando l'energia di una lampadina
alcune centinaia di watt in questo
momento i sistemi di calcoli stiamo di
calcolo che abbiamo al cineca bologna è
un sistema che ha una potenza di due
petaflop 2 miliardi di operazioni al 2
miliardi di miliardi operazioni di
virgola mobile al secondo e consuma
alcuni megawatt di energia elettrica
questa potenza e ottenuta sommando
assieme
200.000 processori che funzionano
assieme sullo stesso problema elaborando
assieme lo stesso in modo simultaneo e
parallelo lo stesso problema il cervello
umano a 1 poi con una potenza che è un
tre ordini di grandezza e ha un consumo
che è quello di alcune centinaia di
batta
riuscire in qualche modo mediante
attività di tipo neuro morphing
a simulare quello che è il comportamento
e la capacità di elaborazione del
cervello umano è uno degli obiettivi al
fine di riprodurre
rispetto a quelli che sono i dispositivi
di calcolo la stessa struttura è la
stessa capacità di
elaborazione che ha il cervello umano ci
sono un certo numero di elementi molto
complessi la rete di collegamento e di
interconnessione del cervello umano è
una rete dinamica che noi non siamo in
grado ancora di ricostruire la
privatizzazione di quelle che sono le
attività all'interno del cervello umano
ha una capacità di gestione che non
siamo in grado di riprodurre ma da
questo punto di vista
esistono una serie di elementi che ci
fanno dire che è potenzialmente
disponiamo tendenzialmente
è possibile
realizzare dispositivi che in un qualche
modo possono ottenere la stessa potenza
d'altra parte per effettuare la
simulazione completa del cervello umano
anche dal punto di vista di quelle che
sono le attività cognitive è necessario
disporre di una potenza di calcolo
simile a quella del cervello umano
dunque lo sviluppo di quello che la
piattaforma e al tempo stesso funzionale
a quello che lo sviluppo della
conoscenza del cervello da questo punto
di vista è dunque indispensabile
realizzare una piattaforma tecnologica
da quella che stiamo facendo dal punto
di vista informatico che metta assieme
le i vari livelli quindi il livello
neuroscientifico il livello neurologico
e livello di quelle che sono le
applicazioni come dire in un'unica
piattaforma dove
le competenze lavorano e sono in grado
di collaborare sullo stesso problema la
prima cosa che dobbiamo risolvere che
stiamo facendo è quella di diciamo
applicare quelle che sono le tecniche di
big data analysis che in qualche modo in
questo momento sono molto
attive a quella che è la attività
funzionale allo sviluppo del progetto
human brain perché
c'è un problema relativo a far sì che
noi si possa avere a disposizione una
potenza di calcolo in grado di poter
gestire quelli che sono la quantità di
dati che vengono prodotti per lo studio
e la comprensione del sistema del
cervello umano e d'altra parte poter
mettere a disposizione in termini di
potenza di calcolo applicazioni che
hanno a che fare con 6 questo è
l'obiettivo del progetto piattaforme
informatiche per le gli aspetti di tipo
neuro informatico per la simulazione
complessiva del cervello per gli aspetti
di tipo medico per gli aspetti di tipo
diciamo di simulazione del comportamento
del cervello come fosse un calcolatore
ma anche di tipo neuro robotico avete
sentito la azione precedente
la sfida che viene posta per quello che
riguarda la neuro robotica è che un
robot che sia in grado di agire su un
paziente per esempio voltarlo su un
letto di ospedale e dunque in grado di
produrre una forza che sia nell'ordine
di 100 kg sia capace però di agire con
quella che è la delicatezza di un un
infermiere e dunque senza provocare
danno al paziente e per fare questo è
assolutamente indispensabile poter in
qualche modo avere potenza di calcolo
adeguata che possa essere implementata
emendata in un sistema robotico è in un
umanoide robotico e che possa da questo
punto di vista svolgere le attività per
per il
lazio ne per esempio di cura in ospedale
a che punto siamo in questo momento per
quello che riguarda l'attività corrente
in corso
dicevo prima che uno degli elementi
cruciali è quello della raccolta dei
dati
i dati sono quelli che vengono raccolti
presso gli ospedali mediante strumenti
del tipo m rai del tipo tac del tipo
radiologico
ovviamente tutti quelli che sono le
informazioni che vengono raccolte da
parte dei dei medici a diretto contatto
con i pazienti ma è necessario andare
oltre e da questo punto di vista
una delle cose che stiamo facendo è
quella di scannerizzare mediante
raggi laser e quindi mediante una
scannerizzazione non distruttiva quello
che è un insieme un topi cavie il
cervello dei topi cavie vivo è trattato
in modo biochimico in modo tale che
diventi trasparente vedete diciamo
quello che accadde prima e dopo in
realtà il topo cavia è vivo e da questo
punto di vista mediante un dispositivo
laser che è sviluppato presso il
laboratorio di spettroscopia non aree di
firenze che uno dei centri di eccellenza
di questo progetto il topo cavia è
sottoposto ad una scannerizzazione laser
quello che accade che si ottengono un
certo numero di fette come dire della
struttura del del cervello del topo che
però è diciamo ad una risoluzione tale
una risoluzione che è al di sotto della
scala del nikon soluzione tale che
consente di poter osservare lo
scintillio delle sinapsi e la struttura
degli assoni questo consente mediante
ricorso tecniche di ricostruzione
della dell'informazione di tracciare
quello che è un
specifico
assone è una specifica connessione fra
una sinapsi e un'altra relativamente a
quello che è un comportamento o una
patologia o una diciamo funzione del
nostro cervello nella fattispecie quello
del cervello del topo in prospettiva
diciamo ci sarà la scannerizzazione di
un primate fino ad arrivare alla
scannerizzazione dell'uomo questo è
insieme la ricostruzione tridimensionale
completa di un cervello di un topo circa
un petabyte di dati un petabyte è la
capacità che è in grado di poter
ospitare l'intera libreria del congresso
degli stati uniti quindi l'intera
biblioteca dunque un cervello di un topo
alla risoluzione che abbiamo è diciamo
occupa una dimensione di questo tipo ed
è assolutamente indispensabile
collezionare molti casi al fine di poter
progredire le tre direzioni che dicevo
prima la direzione relativa alle
neuroscienze
quella della medicina personalizzata è
quella di poter disporre di un sistema
di calcolo o di sistemi di calcolo in
grado di avere potenze nell'ordine di
exaflop
ma al tempo stesso
essendo diciamo dal punto di vista
energivoro capace di poter funzionare
con poche centinaia di watt
tutto questo è human brain come dire in
poche parole